[Musik]
man hasst genommen man muss erklärte die
gedichte die sie vor druck waren auf
eine unerwartete weise
gesellschaftskritisch auch
religionskritische wehren sich immer
wieder gegen den rigiden islam von dem
sie sagte dass er die arabische welt
isolierte der prozess die dichterin von
stefanie brockhaus und andy wolf man
bekommt einige szenen aus dem alltag von
saudi arabien zu sehen zum teil auch
ganz schön heikel weil dort dem sehr
strenge regeln gelten für den
gesellschaftlichen verkehr zwischen
frauen und männern man kann auch einiges
sehen über die über die biografie von
israel ganz tolle fotografien über ihr
leben sie kommen dass einem beduinen
stammen
ihre familie ist erst als sich schon
fast 10 war aus der wüste nach riad
gezwungen in die stadt und sie hat im
grunde die ganze moderne geschichte des
königreichs saudi arabien miterlebt und
auch die geschichte oder eine geschichte
der allmählichen verschärfung auch der
gesellschaftlichen regeln
man kann noch einmal nachvollziehen wie
dramatisch diese castingshow damals
verlaufen ist und wie ungewöhnlich der
auftritt von hissa hilal gewesen sein
muss und auch die ungewöhnlichen erfolg
war denn sie über den dritter damals das
war aufsehenerregend dass sie nicht
gewonnen hat was durchaus auch möglich
wäre wenn der hoch interessant oder auch
auf jeden fall zu empfehlen ist und der
uns in einer zeit in der über viel über
saudi arabien wieder viel gesprochen
wird uns einen ganz konkreten fall einer
frau aus diesem land zeigt die durchaus
möchte dass sich in diesem land etwas
verändert